the winter Marathon starts very soon
it's a 24-hour long tournament these
happen four times a year once every
season it'll be 24 hours of three o
Blitz I don't know how long I'll play if
anyone's watching in the future on
YouTube usually what I like to do for
these videos is just post the whole
thing so this might end up being like a
six plus hour video I think YouTube
restricts videos to 12 hours so there
will probably be a part
two oh yes oh
yes what I also like to do for the
videos is timestamp every
game uh so if you're watching in the
future on YouTube let me know what your
favorite game is also feel free to share
your favorite moments in the chat is
there any chance a really low seed plays
you uh not the first game usually the
first game you play Someone Like right
next to you so I'll probably end up
playing this person or this
person okay here we go I got my coffee
got my ice water
too going to try and be prepared here
good luck to
everyone first
game I'll play
E4 hope you had a great Christmas good
luck thank you tuen I did hope you did
too okay so we have a
modern or kind of a
p and I think I can just go for E5 right
away this is usually the plan of the
setup with Queen E2 Bishop
C4 if Knight here then maybe
E6 wow
wow there's also Bishop F4
but uh this looks
interesting I'm trying to make sense of
what's going on here a confusing
position
actually play C3 restricting the Knight
and the
bishop so I'm playing a fellow I
am Mr ref R from
Argentina okay uh I don't think I want
to take
that maybe just
castling leaving the
tension I mean there is takes takes
95 I
mean Bishop B5 doesn't
work how a question can I hold on to the
pawn queen D6 attacks the pawn twice but
then I have Rook
E1 thank you the idiot next store
appreciate the tier one
sub little bit ahead on on time
here black does have the bishop
hair uh maybe start with this
move Knight A3
KN
[Music]
D2 there is Rook F6 maybe
coming still tricky Rook F6 I can then
win
E7 Knight's ready to come in to help
defend
okay so that was a fancy way of trading
ewn staying up on
time man there's some people who have
already won two games or like halfway
through the first
game uh if I
take I probably should take and Bishop
A3
defending and then Knight three
coming yeah the position's pretty open
which does favor the
Bishops take let's start by doing this
Rook takes I maybe take with
Knight actually let's take with
Rook should play B3
soon
um I should also make Loof for the
king yeah Bishop controls C1 which is
useful black is objectively better here
with a bishop
hair but at least I'm
solid
some
transformation
um play
this
trying to fix this Pawn on the dark
Square yeah I think now I can play for a
win I've made a wall so the king can't
pass my
wall King E4 is
coming
go after this
pawn
bishop is not getting
trapped okay won the first game I was
actually in the stru of end game end
game Cu uh yeah black got all the pawns
fixed on dark squares which
we see does not really help black with
the bishop
situation so I guess this answers a
question from a viewer right before the
tournament if I can play a lower seed uh
good luck to my opponent playing
E3 I am berserking
here so for anyone watching that's not
familiar with berserking is when I cut
my time in
half but if I win again extra point for
the tournament
standings White's playing some sort of
oh White's playing the cow opening Ah
that's
funny White's playing the
cow I was about to say some sort of like
hippo but it's a different
animal um I have I ever encountered the
cow I I went through that brief phase of
playing the
cow okay let's try and take down the
cow want to play A4 this is actually a
typical theme with knights on B3 and G3
to use the H
pawns cause some some
trouble and queen does a nice job
piercing through the
[Music]
diagonal I'm trying to play the anti-
cow whatever that might
mean uh sometimes it's just a matter of
like putting your pieces on more
harmonious squares maybe Knight of four
coming if takes takes I'm not quite
trapping the Knight actually the
knight's coming
here and then take
okay well this is probably good now cuz
I I'll win this Knight or if C3 I win
this
Knight now I win the queen
okay the cow is
crumbling there's still some solid
formation like this
structure it's in the shape of a
triangle can I get my castle
Fork
uh check if King E2 it's
mate oh it's not mate immediately
though okay if Pawn diges Knight I
Castle
Fork a okay here I'll
just um I'll play this it's almost
mating
actually opponent's not taking my
knight I'm sad
okay I'll still Castle it's a funny
move and now let's uh let's finish off
the game no more fooling
around why is the king so
slippery
there we go okay I can't say that I'm
proud of that game I probably missed a
lot of things I'm pretty sure like I'm
pretty sure this would have given me a
Rosen trophy shout out to Rosen
score.com
um
but yeah this is a Feelgood move where
you Castle attacking the the king and
the rook and it's legal because the
king's not moving through check The Rook
moves through a square that's attacked
but that's
okay all right back to
tournament so I've won two games so far
not quite top
100 how did you get the ambulance on
your
name um Lee has recently in introduced
something called
flares and if you go to your profile
settings you can choose a custom flare
all right so I'm mixing up the opening
playing D4 this
game there's a trap here if Queen takes
Pawn the Knight
A4 it's uh it's one of these traps that
a lot of like high rated players will
fall
into I used to get this a lot in title
Tuesday back when I was playing D4 more
consistently the queen just doesn't have
a good square like here here runs into
discoveries so 10 move
win I beat the
2300 much more easily than I beat the
1100 opponent probably should have
played the cow to to last
longer but sometimes that happens it's
the nature of uh of opening
preparation so 30th Place playing Super
sugar I think I'll I'll be berserking
most players below
2,000 um especially when I have
energy are we going to have the first
okay we don't have a Stafford we have a
Four Knights it's a four Knight
Scotch which I have been playing
recently from the white
side E5 I think is a little bit
premature so now there's pressure
against the
Knight maybe this move
happy almost New Year and happy 19
months here's to many more hey thank you
Pablo welcome back happy 19
months it's actually kind of a confusing
position I do like the fact that I'm
preventing white from
castling it's hard to remove the bishop
as
well I'm also hitting the pawn here
we might see Bishop
[Music]
C3 yeah I'm trying to open the
center White's King is a bit
stuck can take
that it's actually very hard to find a
move here for white this Bishop's pinned
King can't
Castle now I can castle with
check man this is almost mate it's made
in one two two more moves or one more
move yeah The Bishop's pinned so he
can't take back okay that was a feel
good
game um yeah I think white should have
played Bishop C3 and prepare Bishop D4
there so 12th Place out of over 5,000
players go back to
E4 no berserking this
game I'll probably end up mixing in some
English and
ready and if anyone else has like a
favorite opening they want me to play do
let me
know maybe I'll play ponani in this game
or maybe a
Spanish
ponan I'll save for
later we have a
Berlin um now it's a four knights with
Bishop
B5 I don't know any Theory here I'm just
going to play what looks to be normal
moves
also still kind of resembles a
Spanish black is maybe preparing
F5 I mean D4 looks pretty standard and
sound supported by
things
Bishop
C2 discouraging
F5 I'll probably end up playing
E3 cuz there might be some idea of Queen
D3 and I don't want Knight B4 to
happen like B3 or B4 and Bishop
B2
how to do
this yeah
B3 B4 maybe could have ran into
A5 Knight's coming to
G6
E5 maybe this
move just discouraging Knight
G6 some ideas of KN F
five some transformation
here probably have to take I could play
KN of
five keeping pieces on the
board
two whole months haha
haa Billy Bojangles how's it going happy
too play King
H2 idea is to play F4 and
[Music]
expand this Knight C4 might be
coming
and this does look pretty good
positionally knife on
F5
take I take on
[Music]
G7
not sure
[Music]
though I didn't want to burn too much
time
there okay now I think it's it's time to
take one year
woohoo
woohoo yeah the combination of Knight
bishop and soon to be
Queen should be pretty
deadly um okay I'll go for F4
E5
okay a clean
game staying clean so far 13th
Place thank you my name is j Jeff
fif the one year with
prime play Nordic
Furnace from Norway provisional ratings
okay
berserk Kings
gambits
to be careful
here my wife got me one of your shirts
as a Christmas gift I will have a
success flown no my queen moment in the
future okay opponent blunders Queen C5
that was the main idea of Queen
[Music]
E7
wow
looking pretty good
here
okay sixth place good
start playing
Braveheart uh no
berserking I'll play it ready
been cycling through E4 and D4 a
bit oh I'm a pro Noob asking for a
bird could play a bird in the
future I'm playing one of
these G4
G4 might come at some point yeah like
right
now another opening I don't really know
much theory in but it looks
fun the idea is to open the G file use
the
[Music]
diagonal if black doesn't take the pawn
then G5 H4
Etc
oh thank you Vester sending love from
Belgium
nice I appreciate all the Europeans
watching maybe are watching late into
the evening or into the early
morning night5 is probably a good pretty
good move it
takes and now this is a
threat so I guess Bishop
[Music]
E2 I'd like to Queen Castle
eventually now we got Portugal in the
house yeah where are people watching
from someone says
London but probably referring to the
opening they want me to play they Rook
G2
here actually might as well just
Castle every Pawn lost is a file
opened got Australia Texas California
Brazil Milwaukee
USA
Thailand Perth Australia a few australas
Finland
[Music]
uhoh let's keep sacking
pawns so my knight my Rook my Bishop my
queen they're all in some sense aimed
towards Black's King
sign if takes i' probably just take
back
something like F4 is probably
coming like the Knight is pinned to the
[Music]
pawn now it's a deadly combo rook and
Bishop oh that move I forgot about
though let's try and disturb the Knight
even more Knight is still pinned to the
[Music]
pawn
so I'm down two pawns
here
taking doesn't quite
work
H6 Rook G4 Rook
G4 just preparing the double up does
allow Knight
F5 F5 is a fork but then I take and I I
get a
windmill so I'm trying to give every
single piece uh a clear job in the
position
maybe how to do this take and
then H maybe this
the bishop was one thing not doing that
much I don't know what I'm threatening
but I mean life looks pretty good
here there
[Music]
there move back and maybe prepare
E4 Knight is now pinned to the H
Pawn
another idea is to put the KN on
G4 oh that's a good
move let's play this I want to play this
next B5 might be
coming yeah blacks played this pretty
well I mean time is on my
side Bishop
[Music]
C2 Bishop
F1 take let's play
this Queen still defends and helps
attack okay always play King
B1 uh where's my
mate
okay black defended well I just was a
bit quicker that
game so top 10 sixth
place mysterious expert mysterious
expert is like an OG viewer to the
stream as far as I
remember and clear
first playing
MV do I play H5 for the memes play H5
for the
memes okay so we'll have
some maybe some London type
thing uh C5 let's play
this yeah it's a double berserk
so it kind of feels like
bullets
interesting so why has the
iqp
probably want to play Rook e six never
mind this
[Music]
move there's a funny
line never
mind Knight C7
T6 on D5 it was in the way of The
Rook maybe even it can come to
F5 hob
hob
get the bishop to
B6 three attackers and three
Defenders now there's only two Defenders
and the Knight can't come back so I win
the
pawn trying to win this
Pawn or
Fork I win the
Knight or
not
okay one on time I'll take it thank you
Bruns wicker happy 16
months okay I'll play the bird just for
the one person in chat that wants the
bird shout out to all the birds
[Music]
watching chirp
chirp there's a few different ways to
play the
bird this is basically a reverse Dutch
like Leningrad
setup probably end up going for E4 maybe
not at least not
immediately I could go for a
C4 it's like a a bonon Dutch I used to
play something like this from the Black
it's a little bit sus
but maybe
playable oh I allow Knight
G4 black doesn't uh or didn't go for
it go for
Knight
95 let's go for this uh go for this move
thank you Vlad appreciate the gifted sub
that's super
kind also my opponent offered me a draw
at some
point but no draw just
yet and position is not looking that
great
[Music]
though allowing this
move happy New Year Eric Happy New
Year I don't feel so happy here
though guess the plan is to get the
Knight to
F3 got to go for that like Bishop
A3
I feel like I'm
coping The Bishop's just stuck forever
unfortunately maybe I can get my king to
the queen
side like the king would be better on
A2 what's that song I'll walk a thousand
miles yada
[Music]
yada
okay I think I've achieved some level of
safety have to watch out for 50 move
roll I've tried but I can't sleep
without you oh my gosh this is almost
mate black almost self-mated that's
funny it's not quite M
unfortunately yeah now we might have a
Queen
trade um well I can play Knight
F3 have to look out for tactics
here
s
this is trapping the Knight oh but the
Knight has that square
what what is
this
oh that was a bad
move
oops at least I opened a
[Music]
file
what my king doing
[Music]
here
okay oh that was an insane game 111
moves oh
[Music]
man okay I'm still clean even though
that was not the
cleanest series of
happenings the bird is unbeatable though
might be my last bird for the tournament
what a cool game okay I'm playing a high
player highest rated opponent
yet we'll play this
opening yeah Knight already has to go
back and then like KN
E4
takes I have Bishop
C3
wow both Queens are hanging Knight's
pinned I probably have to take and
take and black is actually doing okay
here
H3 I'll just move
back probably have to play Knight
H3
black has a center black has better
pieces try to hold on maybe some Knight
H5 ideas at some
point was all time
Advantage take and
Castle I did allow this but it probably
wouldn't work for
black I miss that
move so going for some counter
playay to watch out for Bishop
E3
a I just blundered a rook
[Music]
oops where's my counter play
C4 that's not
good everything's
crumbling
yeah there goes my clean
streak okay not uh not the prettiest of
finishes there but at least it was a
little bit quicker than some of the
other
games next opponent I'm try and rebuild
my streak
it's a long tournament so I have to stay
mentally
tough still top
10 speaking of the bird opening I should
have played the
bird supposedly it's a
word what to
do Oops I meant to play C5 but I guess
I'll I'll play a reverse
London it should be
okay that's one of these um like scandy
kocon type
structures
Queen A5 maybe just H3 or
H6 I'm preparing
C5 yeah white controls a little bit more
space but it's
manageable these positions require a lot
of
patience we'll do some poking and
prodding B4 is kind of hard to
stop although B4 maybe I can
take really up to White to figure that
out hey it's
yannan I I think that's Jan Gustafson
appreciate the
raid if you're just joining this could
be a very long
stream um I started
streaming about 50 minutes ago it's a
winter Marathon
tournament I don't think I'll do the
whole 24 hours opponent wants to draw
but I'm going to try and fight
till maybe not till the death but until
the position actually becomes D there's
a lot of Life still left in this
position also shout out to Yan hope you
had a good stream yanan
TV I don't know what to do here I'll
just kind of keep waiting maybe build a
gun D5 might be
happening
D5 take
take what's
happening queen
f8 queen
E8 idea is now I defend the queen and I
threaten to take pawns Pinn to The Rook
Rook E2 I take we trade
everything que a 7
[Music]
D4 yeah we're trading a
lot I'm try and be solid
here
opponent still wants to draw I'm going
to have a slightly more active King I
think maybe not my King's restricted I
do have G5 G5 is a nice positional move
[Music]
this White's actually going to be the
one with a more active
King so as the first game of the
tournament I had um similar type of of
same color Bishop
ending with a pawn fix on the light
square that does favor
Black White's King is more
advanced opponent taking
time opponent taking a lot of
[Music]
time F6 is
op let's take this
way from H5
[Music]
potential
okay we'll fix another Pawn on light
Square that's
tricky Bishop if Bishop moves I have
this
[Music]
move
take and now I'm winning this
[Music]
Pawn
okay that's that's why I don't take
draws you had a great year in
2023 I'm super impressed here's to next
year being even more
soate Mr Rosen thanks so
much yeah happy 13
months so top eight still trying to
rebuild a streak did have my first loss
playing Wooden
head um I was going to say no berserking
but if my opponent berserks I'll berserk
[Music]
to and this is the first Stafford
Gambit I saw on Twitter that uh Jan
gustaffson was studying with
Stafford maybe planning to play a match
against one of the players trying to
qualify for
candidates
so this is a line yeah the engine will
say White's like plus
two but black has more
development if the pawn moves away then
there's Queen
H4
G5 it's interesting actually let's
Castle oh there's that
move yeah I'm going to lose another
Pawn or
not at this
move self pin for the
[Music]
win trying to open this
diagonal mission
accomplished there's a lot of pins
happening another
pin that's a good
[Music]
move I'm going to go for this and
this maybe this
first
a confusing
position I think Knight G3 is the only
move there's Knight D4
too okay that's also that move okay
Stafford Gambit
success one for one with staffords today
thank you to fact the first time
Prime oh playing Valera that's a name I
haven't heard of in
haven't heard in a
while
um if this is the same
Valera used to be an account that like
would win these tournaments all the time
I'm not sure if it's the same
[Music]
person this is definitely a different
account
so I'm doing my usual thing against the
[Music]
modern um yeah the pawns attacks have to
defend
[Music]
defend I might go for this idea Rook
here and then Rook
H4 get the Rook LIF in Bishop H6
ideas that looks
[Music]
fun thank you saunter sardine
nice oh wow does this work
there's Rook D1 in the
end I do have um oops takes and Bishop
H6
takes yeah it's super tricky there's not
a
five
very confusing
[Music]
position try
this thank you
defax so if takes takes takes I Rook G4
then I
take
if that I was thinking Queen
E3 idea of taking and then Queen H6 next
move might see Bishop
F6 hey it's John Curtis FM John Curtis I
appreciate the
raid uh let me give you a shout out
if you're just joining it's uh the
winter
Marathon I started about an hour
ago
[Music]
and yeah this is going to be probably a
very long stream so buckle up Buckle in
I've lost one game so far but I'm
currently top
10 opponent's taking a lot of time here
it's not an easy thing to
stop I'm still trying to figure out what
to do against this
move rookie four maybe happy 25 hope you
have a good
tournament thank you
sey
fancy so I should probably still
take
take I don't have any tea to sip but I
do have iced
coffee maybe last me a little
[Music]
while yeah black
Consolidated this move D2 coming or not
I got the Knight to
F3 these squares are
juicy okay I'll take the
Rook
okay decently clean conversion I think I
may have been in a little bit of trouble
there at some point but got the job done
playing
CBU
Stafford Gambit time part
two Stafford Gambit part
two Stafford declines though not quite a
true
Stafford generally these positions are
slightly slightly better for black just
with extra Tempo in
development
go for
F5 getting some type of like Stonewall
type
thing Bishop
H7 idea G5 maybe
F4 not quite happening
though
see six
ideas sacking doesn't work
[Music]
F4 F4 is interesting
I can't really
resist idea is to get something on
F2 easier said than done
and this
move yeah very tense
position maybe I should have sacked
there still consider
it I'm going for for
it it's kind of
risky cing this and then
this
it's not simple if I take Rook
[Music]
F1 KN
G5
might be threatening this
now still super
tricky
there
for
oops yeah that was very hard to hold
thanks for all the great content this
year you're
welcome still me's not really close
unfortunately
[Music]
I
tried it's actually a cool Maiden too
like Rook C1 and then regardless of if I
push or take it's uh Rook C4
checkmates okay what to do oh no my
Stafford kind
of I like the position I think I was a
little bit
[Music]
too too um Reckless with
sacrificing
white played well
though maybe I'll switch to
Sicilian or maybe I'll just switch to
fortnights take a break from
chess okay bzerk
back we have one of
these
I'm trying to be
aggressive not easy though maybe G5
coming
okay that's a pin see3
[Music]
coming
what are my pawns
doing pawns are playing Tetris right
now and this looks
decent
oops
let's make a
diamond diamonds last forever
right
uh play this first let's play
this maybe not the best
move
hello boing
chess you're just joining I don't know
what's
happening okay now I know what's
happening uh or do I
hey Eric always good to catch a stream
keep up the good
work oh it was a little bit slow there
good game to my
opponent ah so much
rage hello to cat
thrower I'm not enraged enough to throw
a cat but thank you Al SAR TV thank you
Eric I'm falling asleep here in England
but we'll catch up once it hits YouTube
sounds good good luck appreciate
it it's a long tournament so no time to
get tilted no time to throw
cats play this
move some time to attack
though I want to play
G4 take
take maybe I take
first so if takes then I have this move
hitting the queen and the
Knight
yeah life is good
now this is how to recover from tilt
more than game
quickly so 13th
Place I did lose a couple in a row there
trying to rebuild a
streak
oh playing this opponent
again who I beat earlier
berser what what was the opening
earlier play cilian mix it
up have an accelerated
Dragon F3 Queen
B6 yeah usually Bishop B3 is played
first
so now I'm threatening this and
this thank you
mangor or is it um it's Mingo AR
right sorry if for butchering your name
so many
times this worked out well I won a pawn
um let's not lose this
Pawn oh let's not get forked either in
this move
what to do here King
[Music]
G7 idea is if takes takes takes I
basically trap the
knights I don't see how the Knight is
escaping Rook f8
[Music]
coming
okay I'm just get the bishop
back have to be a little little bit
careful it should still be fine
but this move
this move
[Music]
coming I don't know why I put my Rook
there oh this is why yeah The Rook had
to leave the defense of one of the
pawns
okay plenty of
[Music]
time can I orchestrate some
meat maybe
not
hugging the white Rook with my Bishop in
pawns or bishop and singular
Pawn
okay thank you cap toab for the
bits o playing this
person I like the question mark thing uh
oh back and I'll play
E4 and play a fornite
scotch 97
interesting some weird mutation of the
[Music]
cow Queen D no Queen D3 doesn't work
let's play
this
H okay we're both playing the mutant
[Music]
cow uh let's
play Let's go for
this Knight D4 Bishop
here ah there's Bishop G4
coming Bishop
G5 this position hurts my head
am I trapping the
knights
wow
I'm in
[Music]
trouble
for
was not expecting
that
not the best pre moving this
game to hide within the blocks
pawns okay that
works one Queen
one uh-oh
okay uh what to do got too long
time probably should have resigned
sooner there no s mate
[Music]
trap okay life goes
on still top
20 we have a Stafford
Gambit accepted I did lose with a
Stafford declined earlier but I've not
lost with the Stafford
accepted go for this
sign
trying to remember the
prep
G5 White's objectively better in this
line but there are ways to make it a bit
confusing also uh way ahead on the clock
which is
nice okay so if I take and play Queen G
D7 and it's kind of close to
mating F3 is
[Music]
coming or
F4 94 I'll take
it
I'm probably go for the doubling of the
Rooks on H
file if
[Music]
possible
A5 it's a decently solid position even
though I'm still down a
[Music]
pawn how to do
this queen B4 Queen C5
and mysterious expert has
103 it's like more than double the
points I
have Rook H5
maybe going for the double
up now check
man I've oops just
blundered ah it was so good too I forgot
Knights can move
backwards
that's not a good sign like usually
these mistakes happen several more hours
into the
tournament
uh D4 may be
coming
I'm down the full Rook
here
okay that didn't do
anything
King's
escaping
yeah I tried the stalemate trick I mean
queen takes it stalemate
but uh what to
do I play group B1 not my proudest
moment okay have to try and stay
awake what was my rating at the
beginning of the
tournaments it was probably
2566 then or
2576 or 77 I can't do
that uh 16 points higher than where I am
now okay let's focus double
berserk have one of
these Knight H3
play
A4
ooh I probably should not have allowed
that positions closing down though which
sometimes can favor
Knights
that's a good
move
it's a big
trade I'm getting forked
like maybe it's
okay so I have the light
squares
five oh that would be a
blunder what to do
here
oh
[Music]
no
yeah good
move n what to do
okay
ah see you Jimmy is watching this and
playing with your
kitten fake mouse on a string okay that
sounds
[Music]
enjoyable how many people are watching
with their
cats maybe even cat
thrower o bullet with
duck interesting
okay
so I'm top
30 I think I was top 10 briefly but yeah
we're in it for the long game we play
some attempted camer
Springs already
[Music]
Bishop
B4 not easy to punish this I might just
play Bishop
D6 and then yeah take even play
F5 let this is a pin but this is also a
pin hey here we go Eric just chiming in
again this month to say thank you for
the speedrun series it's been amazing oh
pleasure good luck in the turn let goo
thank you Java appreciate
that okay so a lot of Trades here
another endgame situation
incoming maybe
have this going be Knight vers
Bishop hitting this Pawn
now probably
B6
h
oops oh that was not
necessary take there
there
okay white king is cut off should be
okay
here thanks for keeping me company all
year you're the best my
pleasure also thanks everyone in chat
for keeping me company too I do
appreciate
it turning m Christmas and happy New
Year you too RTR
Bama I'm have to make sure there's no
weird
checks
this should just be a
draw
okay take a
draw I'm actually wondering I have a
chance to take on
G2 maybe I didn't was never attacking
G2 yeah I don't think I did I love these
tournaments according to Google data I
watched the AA legend video 41 times
this year
thank you for being
awesome wait do you watch the whole
thing 41 times or do you watch the whole
thing in 41 different
settings I think the the EUR legend
video is my longest video on
YouTube like just below 12
hours
okay so we have one of these weird sort
of
openings it's solid for both
sides some Central
tension Knight C4 comes to
[Music]
mind then
A4
maybe A4
myself Pawn Jes I
take thank you Casey happy
15 yeah there's C4 and
B3 Bishop will be shut out on
B1 black might have the plan of winning
the pawn on
[Music]
A4
which is kind of hard to stop so now the
plans to attack on the king
[Music]
side something like never
mind okay now the bishop can
escape and this
first that was the wrong Square for the
queen
like really the wrong
Square my Queen's just trapped now or is
it I have okay not dead
yet black blunder is
back not the cleanest
game I think I'm in good shape now but
it's kind of
messy take Queen
F3
take
take play this oh no that loses a
knight really
indecisive oh this is probably not the
right line I'm still
trapped like I'm basically down a bishop
and
Rook after to just hunker
[Music]
down maybe
F3 so hard to play
though
I'm trying to cause some
[Music]
confusion
this is probably the best I could ask
for
oh nice nicely
played
ah almost still Mees not
quite okay what to do it was a really
bad position I was lucky to survive that
long life goes
on um I haven't played the English hats
I'll play the English mix up the
openings a little
bit I think fuja played this recently in
one of his tournaments play this
[Music]
move okay so I'm up a
pawn and these pawns are a bit
overextended but it's
interesting
me both pawns are defended Queen A5 is
maybe
[Music]
coming then Rook
C1 a little bit indecisive here and
B6
just finished up your speedrun 16 really
informative and enjoyable thank you
appreciate that DJ God good luck thank
you giganto
bear appreciate
it
so it's a weird
[Music]
position in
King Safety
First E5 was hanging I did have a lot of
options
there if E4 Knight
D4 i centralize h the bishop defend the
[Music]
pawn like Bishop
B4
very confusing
position
take
[Music]
C7 and queen
A3
so I'm winning a
[Music]
PA maybe another Pawn Rook
A8 now I can take Rook a i attack the
Knight
Rook
B2 being tricky I'm threatening to
take the queen would be
overworked
now black does have
activity take
this I'm up three pawns though so even
if I lose another
one should be
[Music]
fine
welcome back to lightning
bolt everything's stable now just have
to not
flag uh tactics check and then
E4 and there's Queen E5 but I'm happy to
trade
Queens
yeah very classic endgame black can
take the rook's basically
stuck uh with blockading the
pawn and eventually black should be in
zwang or if the king runs over too far
then I'll break
through
[Music]
check
how to do
this gu my king should go to
H6
okay 99
seconds Ed didn't
flag we take those we take those we take
those
bruh
says actually I'm not going to repeat
that
name okay uh thank you mang goinging
that was a wakeup
call we play
Sicilian taking a break from the saaff
rapitor some anti-
Sicilian generally the plan is to expand
on the queen side
here I had a chance to play Knight
G4 maybe I still
will
yeah happy to get the
bishop I'm threatening to take in uh
Bishop
[Music]
D4 trapping the
knights Knight's in the center but I
think it's fully
trapped
okay that's two in a
row
back into the top 5050 on
berserk okay good thing I didn't pre
moove E4
there hey it's thinker teacher
appreciate the
raid if you're just joining we are
almost 2 hours into the
marathon I'm currently in 45th Place
Gambit time let's go I haven't played
too many gabit but think gabit time is
approaching think you lost my
gabit need to find some
gabit if anyone has any gits you'd like
me to play let me know in
[Music]
chat almost complete this move
now I can play this move nice tactical
idea attacking the queen I have the inet
move to take with chck my knight is
getting trapped
though but I'll win a few
[Music]
pawns Knight
C6 Knight
C6 I have not lost a single Pawn
yet I'll continue to win
Pawns and more
material let's
take oh I don't want to lose that
[Music]
pawn uh but for the sake of not losing
more
okay black doesn't take
it maybe all my pawns are just untable
let's play a black m
Gambit it's not a bad
suggestion there's connect 8 potential
still I want to get connect a before the
game ends which requires all the
pawns on the fifth rank
oops I blunder the pawn opponent doesn't
take it
though oh I blundered another Pawn
opponent took
it there we
go oh The Rook was hanging
[Music]
forever
okay I'm sad I'm not getting connect
8 how many Bishops can I promote to
oops let's play the vean
Gambit why do I have dark for Bishops
now
okay I don't know why I decided to end
the game like that but okay a win is a
win sorry for all the young children
that had to witness
that moving
on playing I need gabit to play against
this I'll play um Fabiano's
line although Bishop B5 I just have to
improvise
yeah Fabiano has a different approach in
the main
line looks like a solid
position offer The Rook
trade have the Queen Bishop ay
that's a good
[Music]
move does this work I think that works
that's not good opponent sees it
too oh
dear take
take that was really not
good like what to do
here
thank you kind
person it's just resal I
think I'll play
H5 rning madeen
one don't hurt
me
yeah well played what to do I got Pawn M
thank you mjz
man okay life goes
on let's play a Gambit what Gambit to
play
Budapest Budapest
Gambit the first Budapest of
today yeah very often in Budapest white
gives back the
pawn um the idea going into this middle
game is to play this and
this and then this and then this and
then eventually try and
checkmates
the reason for Rook E8 is to tuck the
bishop
away helps defend
G7 yeah maybe I could play the England
gam at some point
although it is a bit more
dubious Queen D4 is a good move
I want to play this but then each
three so I'm kind of going out of my way
to AV with the queen
trade I think we're both trying to
attack on the king
side light really wants a queen
trade
okay allowing it
yeah this Rook is probably not on the
best
square but this
Knight also trying to find a purpose in
life
Rook C1 Knight
[Music]
B4 his Knight is just going all around
the
board and it's found its
Fork winning a pawn now most
likely although I might just lose it
back oh it's a long variation so takes
takes takes Rook B8 I think I win it
[Music]
back okay uple
Pawn still takes a lot of
work and G6
the dream is to get the double up
like to trade Bishop
somehow it's not
easy maybe I can go after
C4 I've over over defended C6 to
mobilize the
bishop so plan is this and then maybe
Rook
A4 mean
if I take
it Bishop E5 I
take so up two pawns
now
okay yeah that game started as like an
aggressive Gambit I was trying to attack
and then it it turned very
positional kind of after the queen
trade way more
strategic I'll play the
English so another one of these sort of
structures I just blunder
E4 I think I did but opponent doesn't
punish
me
so I'm trying to be solid
here
[Music]
B5 this Pawn chain combines nicely with
both
Bishops start by
taking Knight
B5
so I'm attacking the queen and the
Knight
Knight's Knight's not quite pinned to
the queen it is pinned to our
Knight but if here we trade the Knight
saves
[Music]
itself
oops attacking this
Pawn there's a funny line Bishop here I
take with a rook or with a
bishop actually either move would be
[Music]
fine okay up a
piece Rook
C7 probably the
idea
[Music]
h
Box's been
resisting
okay there we
go it's been a lot
of a lot of like tricky games still even
that game winning a piece
early just takes some mental uh mental
discipline to stay
focus playing vula
[Music]
s play this
move okay playing a aggressive line
[Music]
here maybe I'll go for this uh D5 idea
if E3 then
D5 this is a line usually without the
inclusion of H4
H5 I'm not sure which side this
benefits I do in back the
pawn probably like Bishop G4
coming
yeah that's uh attacks a few things who
takes yeah I might just be losing a
[Music]
pawn
what
did I mute the mic how long was the mic
muted for
oops sorry about
that was it the whole game my bad oh no
uh sorry to the YouTube audience and the
twitch
audience there no uh no sound for that
[Music]
game three games in a row
no I think I would have
noticed okay should be back to normal
now maybe I should keep an eye more on
chat just one
game okay
Queen
C2
interesting why can the queen side
Castle probably
not we do have a pretty typical iqp
position
e
am I
losing I might be losing here Rook
C3 take
take oh it's not
good just got my queen
trapped oh no my queen
but how bad is
this take back take there I have two
minor pieces two knights for a queen in
the line that I'm
seeing all they need to do is get a
knight to
H3
o wait
what I can take here wait a
minute
take take take
take I take here
first and I can take the
bishop oh black is better here I don't
know how that happened my queen was
trapped moments ago but now I have the
material and positional
Advantage White's going to
fight
um here I blockade the
[Music]
pawn welcome back to
Josh I'm not threatening to take because
the
skewer
but now I am King
of8
okay this will hopefully be
straightforward okay that was pretty
straightforward I was expecting white to
play A4
there okay 40th Place 67
points trying to keep it going I might
return to uh a
London oh yeah good luck to Josh in the
upcoming Scrabble
tournament on an mrack to Albany
nice how many people are watching on
public transportation
or private
transportation or Amtrak
[Music]
Transportation I trap this opponent
earlier I trapped someone earlier with
the
line uh Queen takes C5 Knight
[Music]
A4 we're all transporting on Earth
through space it's a nice
perspective Bishop E6 is one of the
better moves also thank you shaku
gifting
20 that's super kind really appreciate
that super super
kind I appreciate all the supports from
everyone helping keep me awake
sometimes chat does a better job than
this ice coffee which is no longer ice
coffee turning into room temperature
coffee taking a long time
here from
[Music]
Poland
it is a tricky opening like it's a
question how black wins back the pawn
it's not super
simple take maybe bishop D3 or Bishop
E2 Bishop
D3 like Knight D7 I have Knight
[Music]
A4 oh I guess Black's winning back the
pawn
[Music]
though
yeah
we'll still go for
this actually no I'm still holding
[Music]
on B4
coming
really fancy
move a force spawn
Cloud trying to hold on to the
this take
take Bishop
G5 what is happening
here this game just erupted into chaos I
don't know what's
happening looks okay Queen F6 Queen
F5
hey it's benon Karen how's it going Bon
Karen if you're just
joining life is
confusing I don't know what to do check
here Queen
G6
there
oh maybe I
take take
there maybe I just do
this
D that's a big
mistake
I'll still try and
fight I might lose a rook but I might
have H6
coming
draw
okay I mean I think black should be much
better in the final position I'm not
sure
[Music]
though yeah L's just winning in the
final position Rook got five apparently
oh and then win The
Rook okay it's a a belated Christmas
miracle of some
sort
not sure what to make of that
game anyway life goes on playing FM
[Music]
yiga I'll play a reverse t
attack be this
[Music]
move now it resembles some
London like committing the Knight early
building my
[Music]
triangle um what to do Bishop D3 is
coming go for Bishop
[Music]
B4 this does allow way to
expand maybe this wasn't the best
decision
oo trying to clamp
down yeah the idea of H4 is to fix the
pawn on G2 and then start attacking the
[Music]
pawn White's doing their own
plans throw in the
check can I sack a
queen casing Bishop E4 it's probably
probably better
to not give away a
[Music]
queen
okay so this defends and also tries to
attack some idea of like never
mind and there's Queen
B5 and this
first Rook C6 it's a triple
Fork
okay yeah everything attacked White's
position okay we take
it 43rd 70
points yeah maybe there were other
opportunities there
turn on the heart o yeah my my watch is
fully charged thank you for the
reminder was charging at the beginning
of the stream I'll berserk
back
um I take an
H4 let me uh still get the heart rate
going Knight E5 I have G3
[Music]
F4 okay now the pl a knight to one of
these
squares maybe a queen to that
square
wow on
[Music]
pant black is kind of
solidified a little
bit
though
no what to do
okay not I proud of this
game uh let me turn on the heart rate M
now is my heart
beating it's a zero BPM which is is not
a good sign okay now it says
95 there we go
okay hey welcome back to
Jay oh still asking my favorite chess
game of all time also thank you manging
oh no my room temperature
coffee some point I'll need to replenish
the
coffee there's a game
[Music]
um I forget the exact name of the
players though it was from
teimo also what am I doing
here it's my 18 months sub anniversary
I'm twins thank you
lirk yeah it's really hard to pick like
a favorite game of all
time um but one that comes to mind is
teim oev against some grandmas who name
starts with a K Kissa Kissa
something features a nice uh positional
exchange
sacrifice also what am I doing this game
my mind is not on this game right
now okay black has three Center
pawns like literal Center
pawns I mean E Pawn is kind of a Target
if I
take play
G4 G4
first
E4 is maybe a
threat E4 is now definitely a threat
Queen C2 Also may be
[Music]
coming I'm fting D5 and
B7 I
take I probably have to trade
Queens and go for
this
o take
take
materials now
equal might be some trading some
pawns
take
I'm still in some trouble
here
okay I won't be losing hopefully the
question can I win
this
very least I should be winning on
time oh I blundered Brook
H1 misses it though
okay not the cleanest conversion but got
the job
done the opening um Team o played it was
like a accelerated or no it was a
morazzi bind against accelerated Dragon
it's already very
positional can probably find it by
looking up his best
games playing gski
all right let's stick with
D5 this
line trying to remember if I can go for
[Music]
C4 although I may have already like
confused the opening maybe bishop F5
first yeah Bishop F5 first preparing
C4
oh but
this wait a
minute no I can take and play
E5 I wonder if this is some
Theory OPP's playing really
[Music]
quickly
King
E7 king7 looks really nice because it
defends this and this so this and this
are no longer
[Music]
pinned I'm threatening this and
this like a very useful bong
Cloud could take the Knight
first Rook
A2
trying to make progress
here
Knight's going to come into
[Music]
B3 IDE
three threading this and
this how to crack the position
though this
move
looks so
risky allowing B4 in some
cases
allows Knight
B3 I
[Music]
mean yeah what to do here this
idea let still Knight
B3 going after the E Pawn
we trade I at least win
B2 I'm abandoning this Pawn
though if we trade maybe I play this
first very little
[Music]
time
so Knight B3 King
B5 oh I got just got mated I had to play
I had to take on
V2 oops
I don't think I made the realization
that the pawn is no longer pinned that's
still a mating
idea okay what to do
55 try and rebuild the
streak we'll have a double
berserk and I'll play a typical char o
con play into this
line I think I'll go for a Queens side
[Music]
Castle never
mind I'll go for King
[Music]
F1
A3
[Music]
B4
this looks
[Music]
reasonable ideas
D5
how to make
[Music]
progress
okay threatening this and
this and black will play Rook D5
eventually or
not I'm so paranoid after that last game
I think this is okay though not getting
mated time is
[Music]
fine D5 is hard to
achieve
oops that wasn't the best
decision
yeah it's really not
clean still
converting
okay I can try and find the game later
Jay um the player is teimo I forgot how
to spell it
though so top
50 playing
mgar uh let's
berserk seems like a lot of players are
willing to berserk
back Queen A5 this is a line Queen B
E4 Bishop
E3 play
this
a nice thing here is whites up a pawn
and has a bishop pair especially dark
Bishop has some potential on the king
side I'll go for this Knight D5
ideas I was about to just blunder
everything
there
that's not
simple defending the
[Music]
pawn yeah what's my
plan there there just
attack
o
fancy
no that was such a bad free
move
ah okay
uh what did I do there I pre moove King
F2 it's still tricky with the time
situation
okay might end up taking a break
soon but let's try and uh fight
back playing this
person we have a a Bishop's
opening yeah this is one of the
ideas get the bishop pair
early
o that's a confusing using sequence like
takes
takes a lot of Pawn
[Music]
tension I'm hitting this C4 is probably
expected and then maybe
F6 so white has a defended pass
[Music]
Pawn very imbalanced
I have the light squared Bishop most of
my pawns are on dark squares which does
complement the
bishop if I
take then
[Music]
take that's maybe not the best line it's
interesting though because after takes
takes and we trade Rooks and then takes
takes takes
I could be mating in the
[Music]
end I'm probably losing back the pawn
here unless I'm
not Bishop E2 to
H have to play
this that's still
confusing
he blocks up a
pawn that move I kind of forgot about
about
there
I'm probably in trouble
here the cool thing about this move is
it looks like I'm doing things on the
queen side but I'm threatening miden one
which opponent sneakily
blocks oh was very clever remov from
White take take
there
Rook still threatening madeen
[Music]
one
some issues
here
I wasn't sure what to
do
[Music]
crazy I'm preventing Queen A5 and King
F1
ah oh what to do that was a crazy game
though some weird lines
I didn't have madeen one my my queen was
pinned
unfortunately
okay life keeps
going Let's uh I have a good record
against his opponent let's berser I'm
try and reverse
momentum welcome to polish Dragon 3000
first time
chat from
Poland
okay ponziani time my first ponzani of
the tournament I
believe I've probably played the
ponziani against this opponent
before we've played 19
times thank you Court two
Queen D7 not a move you see too often
these
lines so I'm keeping the tension
threatening to
take I think I basically got a free
Tempo um play D4
here
if takes I might
Castle because I want to get the Rook to
E1 also defending
[Music]
G2 yeah we'll trade a
bit so I didn't really win any
[Music]
material but I do have a slight lead in
development there's a line I'm looking
at involves this and then
this Rook D7 let's play G3 first like I
wanted to play this but then black would
[Music]
defend preparing this or
this black was threatening
that now Rook
[Music]
E7 I'll be attacking the Knight and the
a pawn wherever the King
goes
hey it's OB be re thanks for subbing
happy
39 uh let's play
this I can move back to defend
B2
ooh yeah this is really close to
checkmates
King is saged between the EG
files and probably the ideal is to play
King F3 and G4
checkmates but Rook D4 H3
H5
still trading
Ms Rook has to move somewhere the the
rank I think the idea is to play like
this
move and now I'm threatening Knight E7
Checkmate and if Rook takes Knight then
G4 and there's no more Rook to cover
G4 okay was a cool meeting net a very
effective meeting
net
okay let's see if I can get a streak
going my ratings been
dipping which is I think typical for
these Marathon
tournaments playing a lot of games
berserking a
lot play this opponent one
before okay Cambridge
Springs this is a safe
line Queen C2 I'll still go for
Bishop
B4 and taking
C5
maybe I should have taken
first it's nice having the bishop
hair
um might as well be a bit more
active I'm just realizing this is maybe
a big
mistake Knight B5 and B4 is
playable
risky putting the queen here but if
Knight F3 I
take
[Music]
F4 moving a little bit slowly
too 96 is was a move
now that's
[Music]
manageable I think this is okay King G3
I take with a
knight it gets weird
though
I don't know what to do
there
oh I just hung a
thing oh no
82 opponent misses
it
some chances
okay plenty of
time oh
man
okay I don't know how I won that I
blundered A A full piece somehow fought
my way back I'm keeping my 2500 plus
[Music]
rating had to make a lot of pre moves
there okay double
berserk had something similar earlier
oops okay this is
[Music]
fine
h
go ah I mean I was l in
time probably have good chances to win
if I play on but what to do watching
with my cat oh shout out to your
cats Adam
Z I think there's a lot of cats tuning
in
tonight okay still haven't lost a game
in about 3 years playing Wooden head
again oh we had that funny um I think it
was a Stafford game from
earlier let's play this the bush
gas
yeah we're repeating the same game from
earlier
basically um what did I do like Queen G5
self pin for the
win okay so there's this idea
I have two Bishops for rook and two
pawns now rook and one
Pawn now just two Bishops for a
rook I could have played
this
[Music]
check
okay got my P Pawn mate I think this the
first Pawn mate I've had this
tournament counts as some Rosen
trophy so staying above
2500 trying to get to 100 tourament
points playing Sven
xxs
um
play we'll play a Barman
variation I played this line in
guar against a Grandmaster from
India I probably want to go for C5 at
some
point but White's preventing
it if I take I could take
and takeing C5 doesn't work though
so C5
immediately take
take maybe I just move
back not the most exciting of
moves
uh between games I can check how many
tournament points I have I think I have
something okay throw in the
check wow King
E2 okay let's
Castle oh I'm subjecting myself to this
move white doesn't go for it
take I probably should actually trade
[Music]
Queens
yeah
just abandon the pawn Mo takes I think
this
works
[Music]
don't really want to
trade should be
six think I have to
most my pawns are fixed on light squares
which isn't great
but I mean if we trade Rooks and I have
the two-on-one outside
majority opponent offering a draw in
their turn oh wait until the move is
made yeah maybe I can try and play for
something
here although what's my
[Music]
plan yeah this go after
G2
cuz the King Pawn ending is maybe okay
for
me
there
that's a really bad
[Music]
decision
ah what to do over push there a little
bit such is
life okay 93 tournament
points yeah I should have just taken the
draw
but life goes on um I'll play
E4 we'll have Oops I meant to play the
orthosnap but now we have whatever this
is E4
C5 um the Tilt
opening what is this check
C6 trying to invent a new gabit
here
okay I'll play Queen
C2 not proud of this
opening it could be worse
[Music]
so
A3
wow I mean Knight B3 is an
idea if I
take take and play
E5
there's a line where I just build up a
big Center like I give away the
Rook but the center is pretty nice
here pawns are I guess
[Music]
equal
yeah somehow I'm I'm turning in the
turning the opening blunder into some
sort of
Gambit
also I might have to take a pause after
the next game just realizing
something yeah I mean I'm going to have
to
um I'm going to have to address
something before the next
game something I don't really want to
address
but uh what to
do
H3
I just Bon Cloud King
E2 there are issues with takes and
Knight
C3
I'm like my
chances up over a
minute the center is
intact Bishop G5
wow I play
H4
letbe just this
move complete
development G2 is
hanging could play
G4 ni's just chilling in my
crib Knight on E3
but I don't think it's really going
anywhere oh it's going somewhere
though
uh
Bishop okay I'll allow
N4
now this is
coming I could have played this right
away but it's hard to
stop Rook
D6 hey it's charma winter marathon time
for a 24-hour Eric Rosen stream um quack
quack quack it's possible I guess quack
quack where's my where's my
tactic where's my
quatic maybe I'll just Queen a
pawn um that was not the best
move take take let's play
this
o don't hurt
me
okay oh that was a messy finish okay
let's address the thing I'm pausing the
tournament I got a message from
leas uh
how do I show
it this is my most recent message from
Lee house so it's it's a good thing
but there was apparently one opponent I
was playing that was not playing
fair
so now now I'm curious which game it was
I got refunded nine
points
um yeah usually when this happens like
it happens not when I'm
streaming when leest actually like
detects
account so I don't know if there's an
easy way
to to
see I could just go
through it looks like everyone is
fine I really just want to see the
[Music]
game no it's fine
fine oh but I have to click over their
name how do we know he isn't just that
guy wait who's who guy which
guy I actually don't know if there's an
easy way way to
see
uh I lost nine
points will it be exactly nine points
though oh here we go okay so this was
the
game this was from a this was actually
from a while
ago
actually during this game I wasn't
suspicious at
all and
quite but white did play like very very
cleanly I do remember this
game
okay well kudos to leas for being quick
for enforcing fair play
also thank you sleepy lab Happy 10
months okay playing VES
Chas we played once
before ah that was a game where I
trapped the KN in the
center
okay what would it take for you to
stream the whole tournament a lot of
coffee way more coffee than I have right
[Music]
now maybe some highly caffeinated
tea a few breaks as
[Music]
well I'm rning made in two
well my opponents see
it okay they saw
it E4 might be
[Music]
coming Bishop G6 I'm going to leave the
Knight
here not sure if I'm really achieving
much King
f8 I'm defending this which I guess was
hanging for a couple
moves
uhoh I
take Tak doesn't
work we can Uber eat you
Starbucks I have a coffee machine at my
place thanks for the offer
though I play
F5 although Starbucks does sound
appetizing
ooh wait a
minute I just play Rook
H6 and then queen
h8 and the Knight can't move here and it
takes a few moves for the bishop to do
anything
[Music]
thing now this is working out play
G5
go for some G4
ideas maybe
G3 I have um a a
Nespresso it makes uh coffee out of the
pods
also what am I doing here to have to
move a little bit quicker thank you
Christine HB gifting to
Huda I'm realizing the bishop wants to
be on
[Music]
H4
maybe some
G3
okay white did did not miss or did not
see the threat just missed the
threat okay I'm still staying above
2500 keep it going playing
parkour I have a good score
against have a for Knight
scotch
A5
oh that was a mouse uplip I'm giving
Rook odds
[Music]
now oh so
sad a good position
too
[Music]
can't really
avoid maybe I can losing a bishop
though
there goes my
king
fancy What's the longest game for
lechas
probably not the best use of
time I want a
rook
oh opponent prevented my pre-move what
to
do ah wait how many moves was that
game 192 moves that might be be my
longest game ever it's probably like
100% accuracy too right request computer
analysis or at least 99%
accuracy like we probably played at 100%
for last like 100 moves of the
game I don't want to break the server
[Music]
though
okay maybe I'll check on it
later oh this opponent okay I remember
last few games we
played um play ponzani I
guess yeah this is already a good
position for
white maybe A3
coming
oh I have to watch out for Knight D3 wow
sneaky
H yeah I can't get too
relaxed maybe Queen
D2 or queen
D1 yeah preventing the KN D3 preparing
A3 not allowing Knight
B3 and B4 is
coming I've had zero stalemate traps
this tournament it's kind of
sad all my opponents have converted the
easily winning
[Music]
positions
okay going for Knight of
five
um could take with
Bishop this might be the way to go but
then
Bishop let's take with
Bishop it's getting a little bit weird
was box Queen
hanging I don't think I missed a free
Queen was my queen
hanging not sure what
points maybe
earlier oh looks like mysterious expert
is paused this 185 hasn't changed for a
[Music]
while
okay G3 it's actually a tricky
move and Bishop
F6 so Knights defend each other Bishop
also helps
defend
the queen wants to come
in
yeah
still not easy to generate a mating
net Rook
[Music]
D1
I'm trying to provoke Rook E8 so I can m
in
one black is still holding
on
my favorite content creator so humble so
friendly happy holidays smile that's
kind thank you
ADHD okay threatening
this
uh okay slowly but surely
there we
go
okay still staying above
2500 I'm playing this opponent again who
beat me
earlier had the forget our game
earlier I don't think I've had this
variation yet this
tournament I'm playing the Kasa Corley
Bishop D6
if castling I can take on
[Music]
H2 KN have
four take a KN
H5
[Music]
trying to set up Bishop
F3 if I
take just Rook
here
preparing Knight
G4 doesn't quite work though
although maybe it
did oh 9 G4 would have
worked so it looks like I'm losing a
knight in this line but after it takes I
back rank
mate let's go for
[Music]
this
Tricky
oh yeah yeah
yeah
wow okay I want on time kind of a a
messy time scramble
there I'll take it
though we playing this opponent again
feel like we played a lot play D4 this
game haven't lost so
berserking
yeah this is a very classic Maiden
too King here it's check mate otherwise
Knight takes it's also mate
okay there we go oh stockfish refuses to
analyze your 192 move game yeah I think
the cap is like 100 moves or something
maybe
150 so 28th Place out of almost 8,000
players yeah this is an arena tournament
so people can join and leave
whenever playing m something
something play the two knights or
whatever this
is
leaving the tension I want to play
this
mean F4 looks
attractive this Knight's pinned so think
I can probably if I take there
C5 let's take first
B4
first I'm controlling all these
[Music]
squares yeah not what I
wanted 28
seconds black still under pressure the
defile
pin
like it's hard to get out
of black out out of it
though okay now I'm winning something
Rook D5 I
take thank you Ethan the first time
[Music]
Prime
oops oh that worked
out okay
oh Dr Oz new to Twitch welcome to
Twitch how did you arrive
here a lot of people maybe come over
from YouTube Oh playing coach Raven
who's also streaming I think he also
started at the beginning of the
tournament he's playing the bird I saw
Magnus recently played G5 against him I
think I'll do something a bit more
traditional in D5 and
G6 just play one of these
C4 not something you see every
day let's
defend resembles some
[Music]
Stonewall
um I probably want to trade
off
take First Pawn is probably going to
take
ooh yeah A5 is now a
threat I could play A5
myself not the prettiest
[Music]
move
trying to win
B2 question is now
what queen
A8 maybe just go for
this and then
this
and here here take it's not super clear
oh I take on E3 though and The Bishop's
pinned because of the
battery I think he just missed Queen
H4 H3 I think his only
move and the line is H3 Queen F2 King h
one take on
E3 attacking
[Music]
everything
okay yeah
it's um it's tiring to stream this
tournament uh I imagine Raven might also
be getting tired but shout out to uh
coach Raven I think he's releasing a
course soon on the bird
he did have a cool game against Magnus
recently he also beat me in title
Tuesday a bunch recently so it's some
[Music]
Revenge take
here yeah we're approaching the point in
the tournament where a lot of players
are getting
tired myself
included lies help with energy
and streaming oh yes got 20 more hours
to go thanks for the the truth
schwarma it it takes takes yeah look at
my
pawns oh pawns are so happy let's get
more pawns towards the center
please
F5 F5 is not a fun
move I could take on
bant yeah this should be
okay still have to be
[Music]
careful have to be really really careful
we have
[Music]
two
o does that
work I could just take this way Bishop
defend Rook
H1 I got to watch my time
though
[Music]
what to
do oh good move
there's a funny
[Music]
line okay that's a fork but it doesn't
work
I'm so
slow oh what to
do okay 116 points 23rd
Place it's been a while since I've been
in top
10 this I almost never played Knight D2
okay we're
transposing oh what's the line
here Bishop G5 and
C4 just sacking a
piece usually it's F6 where you can sack
the
piece but maybe this is
playable kind of just inventing things
now and take there
there
so I'm down a piece for a
[Music]
pawn yeah that's a good
move if
I
take and do
this I'm trying to win some more Pawns
as someone very wise said treat every
mistake like a Gambit you Gambit the
piece I'm trying to figure out what to
do
here there's almost a funny line
check I want to play
[Music]
E5 let's play
this maybe black will fall for
it maybe not though
though
Ah that's not good
G3 Castle
C4 that's
[Music]
Castle I could
take
I'm just trying to put up some
resistance
here trying to win B7 which it's
actually hard to sa for
black
H4 H4 doesn't work
though I play
that uh there there
I go for
this and King aent one has a
plan it's a sad
move
ah good
oops okay uh what to
do need to stay more
awake almost done with the coffee it
took about it took 4 hours wow
still have some coffee
[Music]
too 4 hours down 20 to
go it's a miracle I'm still above
[Music]
2500 so here I'm playing a reverse Grand
Prix
attack thank you mang
goinging
um not sure which Pawn to take
with might just go for the quick
kingside
attack
Bishop E4 was probably possible
[Music]
there4 it's weird
though I can't I can't take on
[Music]
E3 start with
this whoa I'm just missing a lot of
things oh
dear don't hurt
me maybe it's not so
bad strong Bishop now D5 makes other
Bishop
strong like so close to
mating if takes um the Knight controls
[Music]
H1 I don't want to allow Queen E6 maybe
this
move
[Music]
attacking like how does white defend
now not H one might be the only try
but that just gets
mated
um is it worth playing Rook
[Music]
H1 let's just
take
check check in
here
I feel like I should have just lost this
game like pretty
quickly but I'll take it and tables
turned wow like i' I haven't really been
looking at chat so closely I'm just
reading like one off comments alien an
Farm Earth is at least a deck DOA
hedrin Earth is a turtle
shell Planet equals plane plus what are
people talking
about okay I'm I'm too sleepy for
this all right
let's let's play a a standard
London okay now it's a bit
non-standard each Pawn
thrust okay now I can win a
[Music]
pawn am I losing it
back I guess
not
I should be winning the
bishop
uh I want to trade
Rooks this should be good
enough if I take and then
push
okay okay 25th Place playing gty haven't
played yet is that cheese or
cheesecake not
sure from Iceland not the best
connection
so Stafford Gambit
time um Queen
E2 play this
first
I'll go for the doubling on the H
file like not super easy for white to
save the
pawn although White's going to save the
pawn at least it's
[Music]
solid
o oh that
hurts I'm losing the
cwn
pieces were on bad squares
there getting out
played it still takes technique for
white to
[Music]
win but being down two pawns it's it's a
lot
so I'm down three pawns but there's
weird positional
compensation not sure if it's going to
be enough
though G5
here wait a minute
G6 G6 is crazy if it
works cuz Knight moves and I fork
otherwise night's
trapped so there might be hope despite
my material deficit like these pieces
are
awkward but even if I win the night I'm
still down a lot of
Pawns I'm ready to win some
back
oh the knight's going to
E7 ah it's not so
simple I'm still winning no I'm Lo
losing
G6
okay this
[Music]
move if this I both Rooks got
attacked I'm still down three pawns I'm
up a little bit of
time CH can maybe take
here
take you take
here wooden Shield incoming maybe
probably
not but I'm winning back
pawns
check
getting
closer check
there
feel like I have chances threatening to
take
dups
I'm going have me in
one
a oh what to do good game
though heart rate above
130 I'm sure there were missed
opportunities there tough game
okay 27th Place 121
points mysterious expert is
paused so we move on it's
berserk try and rebuild a
streak
oops
okay this should be
[Music]
playable somehow this is working out I
wi a
pawn thank you to Sky guy easy Sky
Guys oh my ability to like read letters
is uh or read names is
suffering
Bishop should be on C4
here defending the
pawn don't really want to trade
Rooks this
[Music]
maybe
m
this look
promising
hi Eric smile
smile okay hi fony
donkey oh
man
okay let's see berserk bullet with duck
we drew previously
oh yeah that crazy
[Music]
game oo I could have taken twice I
think is looking
nice King E4 Bishop C8 G3 Bishop H6 to
threat to take a knight
D3 not quite
happening I mean I might end up never
mind I'm still close to doing it
though take
Take N let's hold
off maybe what I'll do oh wow Ah that's
almost
checkmates annoying
move how do
I where's my queen
sack I want to sack the queen and then
Knight takes F3 it's not happening
though
okay going after
[Music]
B2 take
take
I think this is
fine Queen defends Knight
attacks Queen really
[Music]
defends and the bishop will
attack
tricky
okay okay um staying
awake still able to win some games it's
two wins in a row
berserking
um playing a
Farmville playing against a
hippo
just do something like
C6
Bishops against Knights close
position
wow
and I have three
coming
not
simple I may have already gone
wrong take
there Eric you are better therapy than
the ad that sponsored your live last
videoa I saw a few comments like
that thank you
snaped oh no my king what should I
do okay another grind
continues 26th
Place oh thanks earlier to J Smith
festal too happy 20
months okay beat this opponent a few
times I'll play a
Spanish
some Marshall type
thing don't really know if this is
Theory looks playable if I take
take to play probably this
first
okay what do we
have a solid position for both
sides okay that's not going to
happen Knight
F5 n
[Music]
G4
ooh that was a
blunder
yeah take
there maybe I can play
this oh that's not
good or is
it threading the bishop some back rank
ideas
and this looks bad I don't immediately
see how black can
[Music]
win my original intention was King F1
but then
checkmates
okay don't hurt
me oh G ah nice
mate G5 checkmates get two Rosen
trophies for
that
I did not have an escape there well
played what I
do that's two losses in a
row life goes
on playing
English opponent not berserking
back I'm going to have to try and
protect my 2500
rating
to play quickly
here
get the bishop
pair yeah I'm trying to keep the
tension Queen
B6 que B6 I guess I can double the
[Music]
pawns it's not easy for black to resolve
the
pin Rook
C1 I think the plan is Bishop E1 Queen
D3 make the
battery oh thank you uh tuna
Kuma tuna
Kahuna continuing the sub gift
appreciate
it Queen D2 attacking and
defending want to lift The Rook
over 4 and a half hours to finish this
ice
coffee which turned into room
temperature
coffee
so if I play the whole Marathon
tournament how many coffees is
that also n6 is
coming maybe I play this
first
I don't really have anything
here thank you
Sharma the Starbucks is closed right
now I'll probably be asleep by the time
it's open unless I'm still
streaming
um let's play Let's Move quicker quicker
quicker hi Eric hope you have a happy
2024 oh thank
you do my
best moving way too
slowly okay ready to
take H4 is hanging
[Music]
though
okay pass a
pawn
m
um what to do a little bit slow
there okay I think this is my worst
losing
streak I did lose three in a row a while
go okay no one beats me four in a row
playing bullet with duck he those
opponent berserk
back they might be less inclined but
okay what was the opening
before okay Cambridge Springs
time KN D2 I'll play
G6
[Music]
kto probably queen d8
Coming
oo C5 looks
interesting and the goal is to open the
position with the bishop
pair looks like I'm losing a pawn but B6
should allow me to wi back the
pawn even in the
[Music]
sign it's a little bit sketchy
though
yeah Knight
D4 I'm not winning back the
pawn or am I B5
bond is very
[Music]
overextended if I
take I think this and
this good
move
there we
[Music]
go okay that was close
prevented the losing streak from
extending hovering around top
30 no one has over 200 first place has
been dethroned by
Sev oh playing coach Raven again I think
K berserk back yeah okay what does he do
against
London Dutch of course E6
G4 okay with this I'll play a normal
Lon but C5 is not the most normal move
you see in
London Bishop
here
H4
oo D6 is now
[Music]
vulnerable but it's getting
weird H there's this
move I think it's still okay don't hurt
me there there oh Bishop's
attacked I'm getting
hurt I have this
move Knight B4 Bishop C4
wow Knight B4 unleashes and obstructs
but Bishop C4 gets the bishop out the
way and
defends
how to
[Music]
defend
okay oh that took work took a lot of
work back on the
streak oh no
parkour that's a long losing
streak okay A lot of people are
berserking back which is
nice
night
interesting okay accepting whatever this
Gambit
is probably have to be really careful
here
[Music]
D7 I might give back a
pawn actually giving back more than just
a
pawn
have some D3
Square
so I think these pawns I can't be taken
I check and probably Counterattack
although I have to go for
this and
this okay winning a
Pawn Yeah Raven and I are are friendly
in real life haven't seen him in a
while um he did beat me in the one TB
game we play
know pring
this oh that was bad
move I'm so sad let's up a
pawn what to do lost Focus for a moment
there
such his
life playing
shuvalov probably not
[Music]
shuvalova
berserk Pawn's not berserking
back so giving time ODS to someone who's
around my
rating uh Play Bishop
[Music]
B4 Queen C2
C5 and the plan is Queen
A5 Bishop still attacked
h i
take
wow
E4 R G6 is
coming
looking good despite the time
situation Queen
G5 offer the queen
trade
I just missed maen one
oops
it's Rook G2 as
[Music]
well
okay oh man took
work took a bit of
work things were missed
yeah got the job done
though okay no more coffee I have my
water I'll probably end up taking a
break pretty soon I haven't taken a
single break thus
far playing
E4
um let's not
sack oops maybe I should have
sacked
okay
I'm already in trouble
here thank you schwarma I feel like this
is the time to play you in a blindfold
simil as you are missing in one someone
call Eric a coffee
ambulance oh the coffee ambulance sounds
nice can they inject me with
coffee this position is not so
[Music]
bad maybe I'll go for some Pawn advance
an
es n
[Music]
F4 not really the move I wanted to play
there
good
move
this it's not
[Music]
working
putting
meat
ah little bit slow there to
do okay
136 leader has
[Music]
211 good number of players are
paused Sven Xs
do I
berserk I think I need to raise my
rating first before I I berserk
more oh we did have do we have this
opening
earlier can't
[Music]
recall I'm going to play a different
line Knight
A6 the KN will go on a
tour
the idea with the Knight on G7 is to put
the bishop on
F5 and
trade maybe not the most Pleasant
position and Knight B6 is a
threat wow a lot of ways to get forked
here may this
move pieces are decently
placed if I
take
the main drawback in this opening or in
this middle game is uh backwards C Pawn
White's trying to play
positionally I'm trying to attack
though
H3 didn't really work
out
[Music]
uhoh that's not
good White's playing this very well he
won the
pawn and D5 is now weak
oh Bishop's attack but I can take
here what's
happening this might be
okay I'm still down a pawn but could be
worse it
takes
okay now White's trying to
attack
h
might be threatening
this
I have
this there's Queen
[Music]
B7
oops What's happen Happening
Here Knight E8 I take and Bishop
C5 I'm guarding Queen B2
check I think it's winning for
black I oh there's a rook G8
though
okay
it's still
tricky takes the bishop I win back the
thing
there we
go
okay okay that took a lot of work
somehow I I tricked my opponent there
getting
outplayed
okay keep it
going have not lost to this opponent
yet let's play the Greco attack I played
this in a recent
[Music]
speedrun see if the opponent knows it
castling maybe I don't know it's
of
D5
okay we're being solid here and getting
some peace
Harmony losing a pawn but maybe winning
the back the
pawn a lot of
Trades take G4
yeah Rook
A8 I think I have to move back otherwise
Bishop
D3
[Music]
rookie two is a a
threat oo some down on a pawn but black
structure is not the
best
oh that the one square I should not have
gone
to
oops I'm so sad
oh life was so good until it
wasn't okay I
resign
okay have to take away some lesson there
I'm 2500 on the
dot we have a
scandy B4 is not
coming I was ready to play the Gambit of
Queen
A5 I might go for a a sharper game
Castle Queen
side I'm five hours in just past the 5
Hour
Mark again I don't know if I'll play the
whole thing if I get sleepy I'll
probably stop
there goes my
thing
um
[Music]
94 looks like there's some compensation
here
wow n
F6
H not
sure sleep is for the week no sleeping
allowed noach go get the coffee
going I might Brew some tea
actually be some nice uh change of pace
also and
I'm seeing so many hallucinations
here probably just Brook
H4 preparing ragee
one like this and
[Music]
this
D5
E5 I don't know what to
do queen
D2 oh charma got a badge for 100k
bits nice
badge yeah the bits are a nice subtitute
for coffee for the time
being
um always play King
[Music]
B1
oh I don't know what to do
here
C3 like I really don't know what to
do A3 I
guess
[Music]
now lock is playing
cleanly out four doesn't
work
dropping the
bishop
a wow it's
resourceful like no
mercy
strange my opponent's moving so
slowly
okay I think I I should take a break
after that game I'm going to take a
small
break
uh and I'll be back
momentarily thank you that chai Town
dude oh we almost have a hyp
train
yeah I'm due for a break over 5 hours in
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube let me know if you've made it
this far hope you're having a good time
maybe some people watching have fallen
asleep also maybe some people watching
on Twitch
too uh I'll be back in a moment stay
tuned I'm
back thank you that Chan
Jude appreciate the Thousand bits and
Phoenix also with a th000 bits and okay
I got some orange
juice which will hopefully be a
healthier choice and more
coffee
[Music]
um yeah that was uh I was better in this
game at some
point but didn't quite find the way to
crack the
position so moving on
33rd You Laugh Factory
Legend playing Tim 4
i09 yeah this is just freshly squeezed
orange juice it's like the Whole Foods
brand
not even a brand it's just orange a
juice from
oranges a little bit of
ice
and this might be the lowest my rating
has been in a long long time at least my
Blitz rating on the
chess thank you dery
99 happy
five
so we both have a pretty solid position
[Music]
here
yeah this could be a long
grind like eventually white will play
E3 I
[Music]
assume wants a queen
trade
no Queen trade just
yet
oh okay that makes me
happy I
think actually I don't
[Music]
know now the plan is to attack the dwn
with all of the
things Z asking can you play one H5 next
time you're
black uh maybe White plays
G3 or maybe I'll just play H5 anyway if
that's what makes you
happy Queen
E7 if we
trade maybe just uh King
G7 there's a line like takes and takes
takes and takes and takes and here and
then
here all right we'll
[Music]
trade I don't really want to
draw
this might be hard to play for a win
[Music]
though
h
take
there
hey it's da what's up da I appreciate
the raid I'm trying to win this end game
white probably has some sa me trick like
just a crazy
Rook I'm still trying rookie 2's
idea
oops I'm in trouble now
oh
[Music]
no I missed a free rook
too
I feel
bad okay no more losing no more losing
have to wake up welcome everyone
joining let's make it interesting as
white win with King's gabit next game
for 1K bits as black win with Stafford
Gambit for 1K
bits will opponent let me play the
king's Gambit please
okay Kings Gambit time let's go I don't
know any Theory here but we have a
king's gambut I
guess
uh let's develop
pieces maybe this
move I just hang up PA I guess it's a
real Gambit now right take
[Music]
D4 I'm not sure how much I like my
chances to win this I do have the bishop
hair
uhoh to be careful touching the mic
don't want to accidentally mute
it
wow
um there there
there KN E4 King
G2 i' like to play Rook e one if I get
the
chance
wow nice move if I take
yeah it's not
great why did I play the king's
Gambit should I Gambit my
king l a
queen I mean King G1 is pretty bad
but let's try it
maybe bishop F1
[Music]
coming yeah the problem is my Rook is
tra my King has no legal
moves also I just got another rating
refund um I'll check it after this
game I'm pretty sure I know which game
it was
though okay Bishop
F1
staying
alive staying
alive
[Music]
h
oops
it's stalemate King's gabit
unbeatable okay the first St meate of
the tournament for me let's go that's
even better than is that better than
winning it's equivalent
maybe
um real quick for the second time in the
tournament
uh I'm getting this
message so I I got another
refund um also it was someone who I
reported when I took a break because it
was kind of kind of clear I didn't want
to call it out
though um it was that this game I
believe my opponent was is taking like 5
seconds for every move towards the end
of the
game so I got some rating refund I don't
know if
I'll I don't think it's enough to be
back over
2500 but uh we'll keep
going 3d6
plays haven't had too many
draws
I do get Rosen truy for that last
game Stafford gamut is black oh yeah
can't play the Stafford against B3
though but I'm
playing what I like to do against
this bishop
D6
think I have to
take what's the ultimate goal of this
tournament top 10 would be nice but I
don't think it's achievable especially
if I don't play yeah if I don't play the
whole
thing
um what to do here King
B8 yeah I think we'll trade
[Music]
down it's actually a good question if
the tournament score gets changed and I
don't
know it might it might not
be it probably does
though play G6 no
G6 Queen
G5 this move
first there's some Queen
H2 Queen
A3
play
G6 if Queen G5 I have Knight
E4 where else is the queen going
F3 okay controlling the
center this is it's going to be hard to
win
though if I
take listening to the peaceful sounds of
chaotic chess to fall
asleep peaceful sounds of chaotic chess
yeah a nice way of putting
it
um what's the plan is to get the Knight
to E5
now I don't think white can take the
pawn even though it attacks the queen
and queen G6 should be winning
there cuz the queen blocks I have Knight
E5 otherwise I I'm going to win the win
the everything now yeah
okay well that worked
out Sharma was asking have you ever had
leas flag You for
Cheating uh no I have
not there's never been a time where I've
played
suspiciously
[Music]
well or well
enough what signs are there that you are
playing someone that is
cheating
um there is a lot of signs it's
something I don't actually talk about so
much cuz if I talk about the signs that
indicate cheating then it
could get some number of people to try
and like get around
those um but as far as I know leas has a
like very good anti-che
system
um
I'm pretty
sure I don't know how to compares to
chess.com
though but they're very quick with
uh responding to reports which is
nice like every report I've sent on
leest they always like respond within
within an hour or
two okay I'm trapping the Knight
okay back to
2500 but there's definitely like the
obvious signs of um like move times
and some of it's hard to describe with
the style of play
[Music]
too
wait what am I doing I just played the
wrong move
order
oops
um okay F6 maybe
no yeah this this is like a known like
slightly better line for
black but I'll try and make it
work p is Bishop C2 and eventually
E4 yeah now it's not so
bad castling Queens
side
B3
ideas to plan a knight on B6
I'm losing a pawn
though it gets a bit double-edged
oh this Knight's hanging
too kind of forgot about that I was
wondering why black was taking time Rook
[Music]
A4
I guess I have this
move doesn't look great though
now I can't
[Music]
Castle it's going to be hard to win this
Pawn okay now I can
[Music]
Castle it's still going to be hard to
win the
pawn
almost have Queen
D3
please play this
move actually I
should okay I have to defend
this
[Music]
wow nice
move I see two's
[Music]
coming what to
do KN
F1 um KN D2
first okay I'm not going to resign
because there's this one last
trick got to
starts I don't even know what to start
with though
Bishop's coming
here please move up PA
never resign when you have a Pawn on
G3 okay I resign never
mind uh 1K bits if you steal me this I
should not have
resigned what I do
okay
[Music]
um buest
no oh I forgot to play
H5 vers
V if I remember in the
future
okay yeah so this is a uh Fun
Line
had something similar
earlier Queen
E2 yeah the plans to Queen side
Castle
so there's some nice
pressure against the queen
side and queen
B4 I'm just trying to be
scary like this mooving
coming could maybe win this
Pawn Knight C4 looks fun
threatening
this there's a line I want to go for
it's probably not great
but actually yeah I culing this and then
Rook D4 but I can just take and win a
pawn I
think
uh it depends how I want to do
it here I'll take on
[Music]
D4 and now the diagonal is going to be
opening some nice x-ray
vision Eric need more coffee that heart
rate a little
low as someone call a coffee ambulance
take take okay let's um actually let's
just play this
move it took too long to see
that now take and then
[Music]
take B3
okay back over
33rd Mader has
260 okay Stafford G uh H5
time no Safford
Gambit can I play a reverse Safford or U
walrus oh I usually like to play G5
here
well this isn't really working
out
okay I'm trying to be
aggressive B should
B4 V is happy that's what matters even
if my position is
very
questionable
Bishop Queen
takes Queen
F5 so I'm down a
pawn it could be worse could be down two
pawns or a queen
not plundering my queen this
game G5
e
oh I don't want to draw okay opponent
doesn't want to draw either that's
good
I think eventually I do want to play
G5 do I want to prepare
it another a
four
o I do have this
[Music]
move then
D5 have this
move
oops
[Music]
h
it's not looking
great trying to trap The Rook
[Music]
in
okay that was a really messy time
scramble somehow I was slightly quicker
oh
man that was a bit
rough okay we move on playing
shuvalov be this opponent last
[Music]
time is my pet line against the
French
yeah H5 unbeatable I forgot that was the
H5
[Music]
game took a lot of
work okay so the goal here is probably
to go for
G4 like some gradual
[Music]
expansion H4
G4 maybe put a rook on
[Music]
G1 Bishop on
D4 yeah this bishop can
move might see Bishop
C5
[Music]
should still be okay Queen
E3 up a pawn
[Music]
here
this is going to be hard to
convert I just blunder Bishop
C5 I did
oh
no taking his in
draw what to
do
that's a good
move I'm going to need a miracle here
I
yeah okay that was rough what to
do
2500 playing great chess
player the first Jo Bava London
of the
tournament this is a line I played
against da few months ago in title
Tuesday it's a nice
line um can win a
[Music]
Pawn Yeah Knight D7 is not so well
known I want to trade Queen Bishop
E6 to watch out for Knight
D5
[Music]
oo
was kind of a risky Pawn to take
but maybe it'll pay off Rook
C8 I can take and play
B5 hopefully I can convert this
[Music]
takes
oh that
hurts that really
hurts please play
this
I'm so sad now two years less than three
than for the love JD
r i One Connect
Four really have to work on not getting
forked
[Music]
I should
resign play a few more
moves
it's actually getting kind of weird here
here I'm turning the Knight and the
other
thing now
this King D4 I
fork I never resign when you have a
night
oh no my
Knights oh
no but oh no actually my
position uh I
tried
[Music]
okay almost had a trick there opponent
was awake
enough okay we move
on maybe I have to play more
gambits should I play the chat
opening I think I should stick with real
things someone earlier wanted a a
Blackmer Deemer D5 E4
oh this opponent beat me
earlier okay time for
Revenge
why why did I do
that it's probably a sign that I need
sleep let's see if I can salvage
this two pawns for the
piece now three
Pawns salvaging in
progress
mm
uh what's going on
here
[Music]
there just
B5
I think this is
okay
d
what did I
[Music]
do oh my
Rook oh it's so
clever and G5 is only
move it goes
[Music]
on
let's
go
what was that game I blund I blundered a
piece in the open there I played Bishop
D2 oh that was a funny
game
okay Gambit paid off
there still looking for a staffing
Amit let's play one of
these
three months
Eric happy three months to
[Music]
Jammer that game makes me feel so dirty
time to take a shower him from a piece
down to dirty flag
him yeah there is a lot of dirtiness
that
[Music]
game Happy Marathon happy
Marathon I I appreciate everyone tuning
in giving me energy when when I've run
out of
coffee still got my orange
juice what to do
here idea Rook
A6
oh yes my
Starbucks hoping I'll be asleep in four
hours but who
[Music]
knows take take let's takeing Rook
A6 looks like I'm winning back the
[Music]
pawn yeah I have
to surrender the
eile
I
mean if I
take this is
scary I think it's
okay
G5 G5 maybe Knight
F5 yeah if I'm not like losing in
instantly I'm probably better in the end
game so I'll win the
pawn if white has to trade Queen queens
and
Rooks ah there's Knight
G6 so there's a lineon uh takes takes
takes takes and then takes then I can't
take is
H7 ooh oh that
works well
played
yeah very well
played never resign when you have a
knight
though and's see if we
can create some trickery
here please walk your king to C3
please
[Music]
oh no my
Pawn
oh F5
maybe take
take wait to
calculate
there
I think this is a
best
[Music]
try
that's
annoying
I can't even move
it okay uh I was trying to set of the St
me trap but wasn't going to
happen Okay
152 all right let's try and stay like
mentally strong I'll also mix up the
openings play
G6 Knight C6
E5 something
different
yeah he's B6 there Bishop
B6 is this in Knight
C6
wow a
[Music]
five
confusing Center we both have
outposts I don't know what my plan
is I guess to
trade
here this
move as the plan is to get the bishop to
a happier
place
I could play
F4 I'll start with
this
no it's not get
forked a good move
still playing for a
[Music]
win
okay uh that took work can you play
Vienna or Danish
Gambit uh maybe if I'm white I can
try I have not played the Danish this
[Music]
tournament okay I can't play Danish or
Vienna against French I'll play the
orthosnap I tried to play this earlier
by I Mouse slip C5 instead of
takes so okay we'll have
some
something with D4 maybe bishop
C4 I guess there's Queen E7 Knight
E2 just realizing I'm
berserking
a title player they didn't berserk back
also I'm blendering a
piece but opponent doesn't punish me
thank you K gifting five I appreciate
it okay this position is
playable play
F4 gain space with the
[Music]
Pawns
swim down a
minute but things are very
solid some E5
idea
oh does it not
work take
take yeah what to do
um can try this
looks
iffy looks very iffy
actually so I'm attacking the bishop
Bishop moves here Rook
H1 Bishop H5 of I don't have Rook
[Music]
E7
I'm threatening this too actually it's
probably not so
bad
check just play
this Knight B3 King
C2
I'm going to take on
C6 if takes I take and then go
here oh Knight Knight A5 will be
sneaky KN there I can just take
[Music]
it's kind of
tricky that's not winning
oh I got a winning position just too
slow I'm so
[Music]
sad
okay Peep and
chuk oh this
um who is this I feel like I know who
this is we've played a lot in slower
games I
think do I play a
Stafford I haven't fulfilled the
Stafford Gambit challenge
yet I insist on the
Stafford okay can't get the Stafford
after Bishop
C4 I'm going to going to go for this
pretty fundamental idea attack the Ping
Knight Bishop B5 that does prevent
me maybe I should have considered
taking play King
f8 good luck Eric thank you
Wolverine
Queen
F4 F3 is going to come eventually it's
hard to
stop it's like Knight H2 F3
I
take and if I play F3
myself
[Music]
no
trying to get something
here
[Music]
although yeah this is going to be hard
to
win I'm restricting the
knights
I's finding a new
[Music]
home
H Bishop
A2 looks
decent Knight C3 is
[Music]
coming maybe I play
this I'm still hitting the Knight Knight
moves here I
check and then I block block The Rook
from doing
anything a there's Rook
H2 taking
no yeah still
equal
oh just was oblivious to the
threat
it's probably not
good
please work please work it might be
working I think the king and Knight are
far enough
away it might actually be
working
[Music]
wow Super Lucky this
game
okay okay thank you V for being here and
for suggesting H5 have a good
night oh good game to peep anduk who in
the chat yeah that was a that was a
weird one Bishop G4 was a miracle for
me playing Dr
champin
uh let's play Let's play a nimzo haven't
played the nimzo in a
while not sure if I remember how to play
the
[Music]
nimzo like C5 and Bishop
E6 and there's G5
KN
C6 let's go for the sharper line Knight
E4
incoming yeah sometimes black will do
this when leaving the king in the
center
okay probably want to take could take on
D4
first and then try and exploit the E
[Music]
file take
take
so the idea is if Knight takes I take on
D4 and then take and
[Music]
defend the pieces are coming
alive
okay 15 move win with a nimzo not sure
if the final position was like so
winning but I'll take
it okay feeling some
energy London opening
time
Bishop okay we'll play this line with
some quick
G5 or G4 and H4
Maybe
for
like already black is suffering with the
bishop probably has to move the H Pawn
and allow
this opponent still up a lot of
[Music]
time
okay see what to do
here you starting with
this let start
this
now sometimes the structure is okay for
black like the king could maybe hide on
H7 although that's probably not
happening and now the pawns I mean a lot
of weak pawns for black plan is a castle
Bishop C4 maybe C4
C5 the time is pretty much level like
the rest of this game is basically going
to be a bullet game
um some C5
idea C5 from black I take
it okay going into
this
now the Rooks are
[Music]
cordinated um start with
this you know it's funny I'm going to
try it it might not
work Queen H4 f four onas I win the
[Music]
queen even here like
F4 um maybe I should start
with let's start with
this please on pant
please no it's not
working okay I have to be careful with
this
[Music]
Pawn I'm winning a lot of Pawns here
wow
[Music]
um
okay CH as a
draw uh I moved too slowly at some point
there I ended up losing my
Rook but hold
on oh
man
okay playing great chess player again
who beat me
earlier
okay Queen's
Gambit
um was it started as a London and now
it's a Queen's
Gambit Queen's gam
accepted kind I Gam here can I make this
an actual Gambit Queen
B3 and then like Knight
F3 I'm actually
Gaming
Castle just allowing black to take the
[Music]
pawn now if takes I win the
queen that's a good move
though
take that's actually a very good
move
so I'm not only threatening this I'm
also threatening Queen C2 in some cases
toit this and this actually I could have
taken on H7 there
what is this app
called um you're probably asking the
chess uh I'm playing on lee.org it's a
website it's also an app
though yeah so now I'm going to try and
win the pawn there's three attackers and
zero
Defenders
um take with a
rook yeah leest is the second biggest
chess platform behind chess.com
[Music]
but it's completely
free very easy to sign
up um
E4 let's go for
E4 it's kind of risky but
takes just realizing there's Rook
B8 maybe it's still
salvageable Rook B8 I I think I have
Rook d8
there oh but Rook
takes
um have to play
this so I'll be down upon
PA assuming black takes
this thank you casy for the
win U let's play this I have a gun
now
have to not allow Knight
B4 oh Knight B4 there is Rook
d8 maybe going for Rook
D6 I'm also threatening this
now yeah multiple threats threating this
this and this
double
attack looks like I'm winning the
Knight unless block finds wow finds that
move think I
can just
take here I play
here that was a confusing move
but everything should be okay I
think
yeah up a
night okay let's just not flag in 20
seconds
oops
wasn't
easy but I got got the job
done hi Eric could you once again please
say hi to my daughter Marley oh of
course hi turns five on Sunday hey happy
early birthday turns five on
Sunday so that's like new year plus
birthday I hope it's not pass your
bedtime if you're watching I think
there's a lot of people watching whose
bedtime have already
passed maybe some people watching who
are already
asleep but we're keeping it
going yeah thank you pisar square also
thank you Pac Shipman and Phoenix for
the
bits still got some orange
juice oh do I have
tactics I have this
move this
move
tactics are like almost working
but if I
take seems very close to
working but not seeing
it I'll go for Rook F3 and just a grad
definitely not P my bedtime M Ros
YouTube Ros YouTube oh hey YouTube if
you're watching in the future on YouTube
let me
know let me know how you're
doing
um what should I tell you two people to
do leave leave a fun Emoji in the
comments leave your favorite
emoji oh charm is going to
bed okay enjoy your sleep I'm kind of
jealous if I take a pawn it's probably
not
good I'll activate the
king so I am up a pawn
here it's kind of hard to make
progress
so keep walking up the
king F6 may be
coming yeah I'm either going to regret
this or not regret
this there's no in
between King has made a
journey
if only this were racing Kings the
variant where you have to race your king
to the end of the
board what am I doing here
G4 G5 oh F5 is kind of a
threat so I play this no
actually
G5 F5 King
G8 life goes
[Music]
on I just realized I'm
24.99 I need one more rating
points hello just turn up Swagger how's
it
[Music]
going
so I'm still up a
[Music]
Pawn King's not getting
mated yeah the pawn restricts the knight
from potentially helping checkmates
which is pretty
useful and if my knight comes
[Music]
in that would also be
useful
where is my mate Knight of Seven's
[Music]
coming have this
move idea Knight
f8 wow it's so
[Music]
confusing I'm not awake enough for this
position King
G7
opposition threatening
this
okay
simplifying might as well do
this or even this first and then
this
oops that was a mous
uplip I lost like two Tempe
there uh it should be okay
though no
draw I have to build the
Bridge wait what am I
doing
there's my
bridge okay just fast enough
there oh man if I flagged I would have
lost black I had a clutch Pawn
I got the clutch
mate I think that's a Rosen trophy right
like meeting with less than a second
left back over
2500 time for
H5 even though V has
left
okay
Al White's playing some solid
setup taking play
D5 it feels close to something how late
are you staying up that's a great
[Music]
question the only way to find out is to
stay up along with me
uh
take
G5 this looks
[Music]
fun G5 is coming next no matter what
and that's our free Queen opponent just
missed the
discovery people are getting
tired I still got my orange juice got a
lot of lot of people giving energy here
I do appreciate
it um
berserk any advice for getting more
comfortable with shorter Tim
um yeah
it's part of like getting more
comfortable is just like putting in the
time um but sometimes the thing that can
help you most with like Blitz or just
any short time control
is um like a good opening repitor and
just tactical
sharpness cuz that's what makes the
difference in a lot of these sort of
games why is my Bishop on
D3 yeah to get good at like shorter time
controls I mean it takes a long time to
build up like good
intuition part of building intuition is
just dedicating a lot of time to like
chest study and even playing a lot of
slower games
[Music]
too okay this is not a good position for
whites like F5 is coming with
that
doesn't
work if takes then I can
take yeah I'm suffering
here
down
[Music]
upon
trying to Z something a four
maybe
o
a yeah
yeah
door
there goes my
king ah what to do too weak too
slow playing
DJ number
40 Play Bishop C4 this game
h
I'm probably should have started with
this yeah this is looking
nice there's Queen C6 threatening
mate and then
F3 Queen C5 King
H1
up two
pawns expose king of her BL
Rook
D4
okay back over
[Music]
2500 170 points leader has 341
wow yeah this opponent I don't think
berserk back so I'll play
play
this think we saw Queen C2
earlier
E4 I have to
take so we have
um interesting structure I I do have the
backward Pawn on
C6 it has two ISO
Pawns
okay I guess we'll
train
A8 trade some
more B4 is a
target can be attacked another time as
well and C6 is equally a target for
white
C5 is hanging actually so Queen
[Music]
C2 I could play Rook a
H4 probably just Queen
[Music]
C7 maybe preparing
this
[Music]
take I think I'll just play it safe Gro
eight no need to be
fancy I'm definitely feeling it though I
think the the coffee is worn off
it's like really takes more effort to
internalize what's going on in the
position 7 hours in thanks everyone for
still being
here how many people are watching that
are still
awake
anyone I play this
move takes
takes oh there's a decent number
okay how many people watching on YouTube
in the future are still
awake a lot of people sometimes just
drift
off a lot of people
awake oh some people watching from
Europe where it's probably a more normal
time take on
F4 it's
[Music]
playable ah but then Rook
D7 I think it's
fine yeah that worked
out I'm going to employ the caterpillar
method we contract and then
expand then
contract and okay let's not get me
why he was threatening Maiden
two yeah
[Music]
expand um make a
queen
okay 7:54 a.m. in
Spain dude from Vienna 8
o'clock
buos
Aris Queen C2 Queen C2
C5 probably just B3 I could also
consider taking
actually
taking in for now it's a free
Pawn I might get punished but going to
try and hold on to
it A4 is definitely the Thematic
move yeah Rook
B1
is now okay for
me oh we got Toronto in the house in
Chicago
India Nairobi Kenya wow diverse crowd
Malaysia Zimbabwe
way oops the pawn was
overworked actually I can take and then
after takes side play C3 maybe win this
Pawn Slovenia Warsaw Topeka wait Topeka
Kansas I
assume unless there's like a Topeka
Belgium or I don't
know
I think there's a Cairo
Illinois okay Bishop B5
coming the pawn supported still up a
pawn KN
[Music]
D5
Yeah question what to do
[Music]
here I don't mind if Knight takes bishop
and otherwise maybe F4
coming
idea Rook
B2 H this pawns
attack yeah nice sequence from
White had to defend my weak
[Music]
Pawns
oops I got
forked it's not so bad though Bishop
G6 oh I can't take the
look
I could have I guess taken the Rook last
move okay this is working
out can I be fancy and play Queen
D2 no
need make Loof for the
king
oops Queen D2 is probably coming
though not
now
I'll
simplify
okay I've been raising my rating I did
fall below
2500 2513
now 38th Place three in a row
let me at least get to 200 points and
then I'll I'll decide what to do from
there we have a French I'll play this
one
F five idea maybe Queen G4 to
start and do some weakness in Black's
territory not sure how much I achieved
there
there should be five
[Music]
threatening
this Queen f8 Bishop
B4
okay that was
nice how to improve in positional
chest uh study the games of
karpov karpov
petan
[Music]
smiz oh coach Raven still playing okay
good
luck I've uh I've won a few games so far
against coach Raven
he's also oh he's not streaming
though
okay play the same thing as earlier
don't worry about the fine for wearing
your own oh my queen t-shirt heric I
will pay fee day for you and my oh my
staying strong 7 hours in I'm thinking
it's time to go full Ham on Stafford
smashings no caffeine means no mercy
opponents what do I do here thank you
fing
Duster
yeah I would get fined so hard by Feer
right now like I'm not even wearing
shoes I'm wearing socks
so keeps my feet
warm and this this shirt's probably bad
right but if I wear a hoodie it's
okay someone call the Fay dress code
please
yeah G4 I'm getting kind of outplayed
here what to do
this I can't even take there though play
B that was not a good
move maybe it'll be interesting now
things are attacked
everywhere some hope
of what am I hoping for take maybe
this that's a good
move really
suffering rookie 5 may have been a mouse
there now that that
matters still some
[Music]
hope a lot of
Hope
okay hoping paid off I'm sorry
Raven I got completely outplay that game
just was a little bit faster there hey
it's gar what's up
gar it's awake hours of
gar hope you doing well I've been I I've
been alive for over 7 hours
now okay
let's I have a win streak I think at
least four games maybe
more
um play this
line
oh thank you gar gifting to turn with
swagger thank you f duster don't feel
bad sometimes it's worth dist drafting
me to keep me
awake uh let's play this and
this
oh does it work though take King
here oh that's a
move yeah that works pretty
[Music]
well
okay on ban
[Music]
incoming
just
kidding B6
C5 ah good
move
I want the
bishop oh my
king oh my king
okay that was kind of sad I had a uh six
five about five game win
streak
okay saff for Gambit time Kings Gambit
time fbe counter
[Music]
gamit Queen
D4 guess Queen
E2 or queen E7
maybe I should have play Queen H4
[Music]
actually just
Castle
there's an idea
[Music]
here I really want to make it
work B5
first the idea was to take in Queen B6
and win something but never
mind I should move
faster
Sleepless in
Seattle yeah I'm basically that with a
exclusion of being in
[Music]
Seattle
oh no my sleep welcome back T
baggin okay let's focus
here 19
seconds decent position but it's kind of
crazy
oh no that was bad REM
moove
D oh
sad oh had some
chances
I'm top 30 didn't realize
that
um berser King is risky
here we have a
PS play F4 a delayed King's
Gambit
what am I doing with my
pawns if I take take
take doesn't quite
work
Bishop
[Music]
D6
okay short
[Music]
position
black allowed the
fork
man I'm a little bit sleep
surprised this should be working
out why am I so
confused okay opponent's even more
confused
okay
oh top 25 let's go almost to 200 points
once I get to
sorry about that uh sometimes I like I
adjust the mic and then I press the mute
button have to try and disable
that was I muted for a long time sorry
about
that it happened earlier this stream too
uh what to do see5
[Music]
coming okay trying to have some
fun Queen
check
wow and queen C6 looks pretty deadly for
white oh oops thought I could just play
E3
okay and I'm down on
time there goes my
queen opponent
Frozen
um now I feel
[Music]
Frozen
I'm too
slow uh I should have taken a night when
I had the
chance good evening Eric hope you're
doing
well I'm doing okay I'm still alive
that's what I'm matter
is uhoh OPP's not berserking back I'll
play B3 and gab it a little
bit and F6
[Music]
G4 it's actually a funl looking
opening
Queen
h8 let start with
F4
my girlfriend is mad at me for focusing
on chess more than
her I wish I can help you
out I guess I could help by ending the
stream I wonder like how many
girlfriends would be like happy if I
ended the stream right
[Music]
now I'm very low on
time
also down upon
maybe something to hope
for take a
knight yeah how is black
defending I pre-move
this okay let's
um play this
first
this is still going to be hard to
convert or will
it
a little bit slow there I mean every
move had to be a pre for the rest of the
game to win
that playing sahaya I beat
before okay we'll play
this gab it a little
bit
whoa what does this
move should I be
afraid a bishop
here okay time to
run plan is to run and then hide and
then probably run some
more
yeah there's
no is there any
hiding this
move this is
[Music]
terrifying so this defends offers a
bishop trade
I'm also threatening to do this which
leads to
this I don't know if that's good for me
though
G4
[Music]
that's not good okay I mishandled
that
okay I have two goals get to
and um get to 200 turnament
points okay let's play this
line This is a fun
line
of a weird Lon opening type
thing
this
now
turning
this this could get
[Music]
wild
I think it's working
out it was a cool
[Music]
game
oops
okay 193 tournament points
[Music]
2501 Let's uh try and get a couple more
wins here
oh this opponent didn't berserk
before okay have my work cut
out I like this line
though we're going to see
E6 Knight H6 is the best
move
h
nice little ttic
there hitting this this and this
okay let's get one more one more
berserking
game play a
Carol
so now there's this
idea think I still go for
this
I think the Rook sock is incoming if
Knight H7 I sack The
Rook but even if like Knight
anywhere so black gives a
knight probably
[Music]
F4
four because here I can
take I'm really sure it works check
there
there I'm going to feel bad if it
doesn't work work but this better work
check and then Queen
[Music]
here
Jack insisting on the
sacrifice that's a cool attacking
game
okay back to
tournament um I think what I'll
do I I do need sleep I think I'll keep
playing until I lose if I lose a
game then I have to win one more game to
end the Stream if that makes
sense because I want to finish on a
win but if I lose a game the stream will
probably end
soon whoa what is this
move Ono free
nights okay winning in a moves if I keep
winning I could be here for for a long
time top 20 let's
go haven't been in top 20 in a
while opponents are also very tired yeah
bullet with a
duck here we
[Music]
go oops I hung a pawn maybe it's not
that bad though I get this check
in like C4
for yeah this is hopefully
salvageable
B3
[Music]
C4
well
oops forgot that was
possible
[Music]
h
d
ah
okay let's do one
more one more let's end with a win I'll
probably probably wrap things
up but I'll be back for the the finale
of this
tournament
okay no
mercy this is the first Catal I'm facing
today play
B5
okay this Knight is trapped
[Music]
forever oh white did have Knight D2
actually a brief moment
there U I have this
move
okay oh no my
queen oh yes my triple
Fork I missed a
fork I found a
fork
okay I think we'll end with that
pause 255 209
points pausing in top 20 I probably
won't stay there for much
longer but uh yeah I think it's time to
get some
rest so that'll be part one of the
YouTube
video if you're watch watching on
YouTube let me know if you made it this
far I think only a small percentage of
people make it this far at least
according to past retention
graphs thanks to everyone on Twitch also
appreciates everyone tuning in is there
anyone watching the whole
time I think a lot of people came and
went over the course of the last almost
eight hours
is Alex wner here the whole
time Pizza racer on and off since the
start I could use some
pizza right now that would be
nice
anyway
um I sent
something this this Worth
showing oh this is Worth
showing rton cup let me show
this a friend sent me a funny
[Music]
game um
broadcasts okay we're going to end with
this so there's a tournament going on in
Sweden it's a realin cup strong open
tournament believe anak cramling is
playing in
it oh is there an ad going right now oh
there's an ad going
ooh maybe I I hold off or maybe I
explain so anyway
um there's a game between these two
players black is a
grandmas white is Untitled but rated
Fay
and in this
position Black's completely winning it
looks like the Pawn's about to
promote white played the move Rook
E3 black played
A2
and everything seems hopeless cuz now
the Pawn's about to
Queen
[Music]
Etc but wa to
move and survive wa to move and force a
draw I'll give people a moment some
people maybe see
it
yeah so the move that was
played I think the the next move was the
final move of the game and the players
agreed to a
draw Queen to
h8 oh no my
queen after okay if the king were to
take Rook
H3 and White's going to be stalemated by
force Bishop takes it's stalemate
Queen and Bishop cover all the squares
from the King and if King
g8s Rook h8 oh no my Rook black has to
take and it's stal
mate oh that's a very good point
actually Queen h8 was not the best
move the best move was Queen
H7 giving black the choice to move here
so white can
Checkmate oh that's like six
head Queen h8 was played in the game but
nice job finding the
Improvement of course yeah the king
should take and it's a
[Music]
transposition okay